what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and that is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these live streams let's get
this video to 2 000 likes and while
you're at it guys get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today if you want
to be the ultimate alpha male and have
women come up to you left and right get
yourself a women's shouldn't vote
t-shirt also if you are in London we are
doing a meet up on Sunday if you want to
know information on that make sure you
sign up to our Google forms in the
description below okay guys so today I'm
going to be covering a moment that
happened on my show so I think a lot of
times you guys think that I just make
this these things up you think Pearl
just oh you're just a doomsdayer and the
stuff you say is so hypocritical and
you're just you don't know what you're
talking about
now I'm going to tell you guys something
you can't get a degree to do what I do
you really can't
um the things that I say come from over
a year and a half of interviewing woman
after woman after woman and noticing
patterns and Trends in the media in
person on the streets you know you
really can't get a degree to do what I
do so you know one thing that I I say is
that modern women today are entitled
they think that the world should cater
to them and they're gonna get in your
industry and sue you like this is
absolutely what women do they cry
harassment cry oh boo hoo I'm a woman my
life is so hard don't believe me let's
look at a moment from my show well what
is it there's a couple things first of
all my friend is very qualified um she
graduated from Colombia she had like
multiple like already like some years of
experience women always think they're
qualified I mean if we're going to talk
narcissism women always think we're more
qualified than we are okay but okay she
had her degree whatever she had her
degree from like one of the most
prestigious universities I think those
well if I ever if I haven't met so many
dumb people from those universities
but I I don't think that that really
means much okay and my brothers my
brothers all working and I've ten
siblings half of my family is literally
engineers it doesn't matter not much no
I just think okay so so she got a prissy
degree who cares okay I think that if
you're gonna say like oh no like a lot
of women get these positions that they
don't deserve blah blah it would make
more sense to be like oh you know I
don't think um you have enough
experience to do this versus you're a
woman but but see the the men don't
really have a say so the higher the guy
that's be that's hiring like they have
they have to do it for their diversity
hires okay and and again that's you
telling men how to talk and this is my
problem I say if you want to be in a
man's world be in it and stop [__]
complaining I'm so sick of women going
into into men's workplace we ask to be
in the workforce so stop [__] whining
when you get into a man's job and they
make jokes you don't like they start
talking to you the way that you don't
appreciate and they don't say it how you
think you should they should say it
because all it is is narcissism where
you're going around telling everybody
how to talk and bitching and whining for
women like like me and other women that
have worked in male environments and
didn't whine and didn't complain and
just did the work if my boss asked me to
get coffee because I was a woman I
wouldn't give a [__] I wouldn't complain
I would just go get it because I don't
[__] and moan about [__] nothing
so basically what happened was this girl
came on my show
and she was encouraging her friend to
sue her employer because he said that
she can't do things because she's a
woman ladies boo Who Cry Me a River
Cry Me a River you know men go to work
they get made fun of they're
discriminated against you everybody has
problems my point is if you just do the
work and stop whining and bitching and
complaining then if you're talented and
you're actually good at your job it's
going to show through you know
discrimination doesn't help in
capitalism but the problem is we go to
these prissy schools than we think we're
so amazing then we we get jobs that are
filled by quotas I know for a fact a lot
of engineering firms are recruiting
women
um just because they need women in
engineering not because they're more
qualified they get these jobs that they
don't really deserve and instead of just
being happy to be there they whine [__]
and if the guy says anything they don't
like they sue and and the thing is these
women get in these high paying roles
they think they're more important than
they are and then they just spend all
their money on shopping but I'm sure if
you're watching this program you're a
more reasonable person so if you're
unsure about your finances you look at
you're not alone all these crazy chicks
are with you but that is why noble gold
Investments is here to help just hear it
straight from the folks that they have
helped the noble gold crew walked me
through everything no stress with their
help I can finally sleep easy at night
and now this month Noble gold
Investments is handing out a free 5
ounce silver America the Beautiful coin
if you qualify for an IRA invest in gold
and silver with Noble gold Investments
go to noblegoldinvestments.com now
that's noblegoldinvestments.com the only
gold company that I trust and this goes
back to my point of the general trend of
women
Sue and everybody and just ruining
everything a lot of the time now I don't
say this in a happy way but when you
have men that have careers that they've
spent their entire lives building ruined
by one woman
you know this is this is what we get so
I have an update on the Russell Brand
case so Russell Brand has been a
YouTuber podcaster for over a decade
this man has been in the Limelight he's
been an actor like we've always loved
Russell Brand he's hilarious he married
Katy Perry he was he was in a bunch of
really big time movies and you know
recently he's had allegations come out
that he sexually assaulted a girl who
was 16 years old and you know
allegations do not mean a conviction but
unfortunately for YouTube YouTube has
announced that Russell Brand will no
longer monetize his content on the
platform following not convictions but
an allegation of sexual assault made
against him by multiple women the BBC
has also removed some of Bran's material
from its streaming archive brand denies
these allegations and has not faced
criminal charges the suspension of
monetization affects all channels
associated with him impacting his
ability to earn money from ads on
YouTube videos shows brand still
maintains a presence on platforms like
Rumble X formally Twitter and Instagram
these allegations against him date from
2006 to 2013 with a new report of sexual
assault dating from 2003. Bran's career
known for his stand-up comedy and media
appearances has faced consequences as
he's been dropped by talent agencies and
Publishers the long-term impact of his
comedy career remains uncertain okay but
this is my point so these are all
allegations now how many women I was
thinking about this how many women has
he slept with so if he slept with let's
say 500 women
which isn't implausible or a guy that's
been in the Limelight this long like
guys men like him don't have a problem
getting sex okay women throw themselves
at him left and right uh what like what
is the allegation to sleeping with women
ratio
um so I just have a hard time really
believing
um these stories because it just doesn't
seem like a guy in that position would
do that and so there's a guy named Jake
shields on Twitter who really broke this
down
um he said here is a breakdown of the
sexual assault allegations against
Russell Brand
um dated for three months but because
she was young but legal she later
decided it was rape two I had been
sleeping with her but invited her over
for a threesome and she was jealous so
that's rape three was in the room so he
kissed her and tried to take off her
clothes
she told him to stop and he did he had
sex with her for six months and he did
lots of kinky sex she never said no but
thought she didn't want to do it so it's
rape none of these girls give their real
name so you know guys here's the thing
um if you're gonna come forward you
really need to put your name on it and
the other thing is you know I'll give
you like six months to report something
but 10 years later
um and now when he's famous successful
and he's not doing all the crazy stuff
now I you know outside looking at it's
possible there's more evidence that'll
come out but this doesn't make sense to
me Kathleen says maybe he should just
keep his pants on but why is it always
the the man should keep his pants on
maybe the women should keep their legs
closed
that's like okay the equivalent of that
is giving cash to a homeless man
and being mad that he took it that's the
equivalent Earth to Rose men shouldn't
have sex with any woman they don't
intend to marry or at least be in a
serious relationship with people can Aid
on Christianity all day long but there's
wisdom behind the ideas that we're
finding out in real time yeah but wives
do this [__]
one one again they always like I just
want to point out every time we we say
something that makes the woman look bad
they find a way to blame it on the man
always like without this is why guys the
tradkins drive me nuts because we should
have stuff that we agree on and then
they still find a way to blame it on the
man do you know what my disappointment
is from the tradcon community it was so
interesting I um released the footage
last episode proving that Crowder was
not in fact an abuser not not an abuser
The Nanny admitted he wasn't an abuser
um his wife admitted he wasn't an abuser
not an abuser point point blank case
period and you know what's interesting
none of the chadcons reported on it none
where is the outrage where is the
Affinity to clear this man's name that
you guys have drugged through the mud
for six months and guys watch closely to
see who offers retractions and who is
quiet because that's going to tell you
who cares about the truth and who cares
about making money I don't even
necessarily fault them for getting it
wrong we all get [__] wrong at times we
all make mistakes nobody's perfect but
the fact that they've disparaged this
guy's name for six months and now
nobody's offering retractions or
apologies uh it's just not it's not a
good look for tradcons so you know back
to women just not really being loyal
um you know there's another guy whose
case I I haven't followed crazy close
but I more wanted to point out the trend
so any Masterson was That 70s Show actor
I mean I think everybody knows loves him
from That 70s Show and again guys it's
the same sort of trend right that we see
where a guy
has a long career he has a lot of money
he has a lot of success and it always
seems to be when he settles down and
picks a wife that these women start to
come out of the woodwork and now he's a
rapist
but the trend that I wanted to point out
is really the lack of loyalty when men
get really long life sentences
and maybe you can understand maybe she
thinks he's an abuser I don't know but
I'd imagine her experience with him
isn't the same so Bijou Phillips files
for divorce from Danny Masterson
following his 30th year to life rape
sentence sites irreconcilable
differences yeah and this is the trend
you know
um women really don't seem to stick it
out it's more of the exception rather
than the rule they're thick and thin
thin El Chapo's wife I'll say that's an
exception that woman was like I hear no
evil see no evil I never saw him do
anything illegal served two years but
it's rare to find women like that
anymore
but you know I'd really like to see them
revisit his case because uh you know
guys it's like how many times can we see
the same thing where it's like all of
these women come out in hysteria 10
years 15 years after I really think
there needs to be like a year
cap on being able to file charges it
just gets too messy and it gets too much
he said she said and I just think it's
too complicated when you wait too long
so it's like you have a year file the
charges or move on
and the problem with this stuff is it
actually does affect real victims women
that actually have been raped have been
abused when you have women coming back
that that dated the guy you know what I
mean like okay I could see maybe a
one-time thing it could have happened I
could see maybe you know if he pulled
you off the street but like why would
you be in a relationship for months with
a guy that's a abuser
a rapist like that doesn't make sense to
me so Sean Strickland the new UFC world
champion is going viral this week with a
clip on how tough it is to be a man in
today's society let's tune in the moment
you open your eyes and you see what
Society has done to man it is [__]
rough it would be an easier time to be a
man in 1942 than it is a man in 2023.
you might die but you come back and you
know 1946 or whatever World War II ended
you could go be a mechanic you could get
paid a living wage you get respected you
can raise a family you probably have
some God in you because that was before
it got washed out and you have a good
life fast forward to 2023 so you have a
kid he's going to be raised by a school
system that indoctrinates him into other
[__] trash you cannot filter out the
damage from society so now you're an
adult you have no moral backing you have
no real constitution of what right is
wrong is all you want to do is you want
to get laid you want all the money
because that's what you see on the
Instagram they took all self-respect
from men you can't be a man and go be a
mechanic and support a family government
robs you the CEOs rob you you're in a
[__] awful awful place right now to
be a man yeah
and he's absolutely right average men
don't get the respect that they used to
I I see this not only in society from
women but I see it from the top men you
know I'm really tired of seeing like the
CEOs the business owners not having
respect for the average men and even
this goes for influencers too guys we
could not do what we do without the men
that build and run this Society 45 of
men
help run the infrastructure of society
they either paved the roads build the
buildings do the plumbing build the cars
work at a factory like these we need
these men in order to survive and the
thing is you know
we have this like hustle culture where
where it's always make more money
you're you don't deserve a woman
if you don't give her this pampered
prissy lifestyle and it's unfortunate
because we've just lost respect for the
average man and what I like about Sean
Strickland is that you can tell he
really respects the truck drivers he
really respects the men that build the
society and he's right we have lost God
we have lost the things that made
America great
and a lot of men are being robbed in
this Society but if you're tired of
being robbed by inflation and the
government why don't you take control of
your finances do you not know where to
start well Noble gold Investments
understand investing in Precious Metals
may sound confusing but the team at
Noble gold Investments makes it easy
let's hear from actual Noble gold
investment customers the staff answered
all of my questions and helped me every
step of the way no pressure sales
tactics just honest guidance securing my
Futures less stressful thanks to Noble
Gold's expertise don't settle for
financial uncertainty they will suggest
options and see if you can diversify
into gold and silver right now Noble
gold Investments is offering a free 5
ounce silver America the Beautiful
bullion coin for qualified accounts
don't settle for financial uncertainty
noblegold Investments has an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
and countless five star reviews why wait
go to noblegoldinvestments.com
noblegoldinvestments.com that's the only
gold company that I trust okay so you
know one question that I get like pre I
guess pretty often is people want to
know my background they want to know how
I became a conservative and it's really
interesting because if I take a
personality test it actually says I'm
super liberal like it says I have a
90-something percent chance of being a
liberal and I guess like some of the
traits or the qualities that I have um
like liberals tend to have some very
creative you know that's why you see all
the hippies and the Vans
um they're usually more liberal you know
I'm very open so I'm open to new
experiences
um I'm low I think I'm low in
conscientiousness which like tends to go
more with the Liberals and so a lot of
people have asked me like how did you
become conservative and um I would say
growing up like
I wasn't as conservative as I am today
but I've always like leaned right so you
know I've always been pro-life pretty
much I've always
um I mean I'm a woman so there's you
know I've had moments but overall like
I've always been pro-life I haven't
believed in high taxes and I would say I
was more of a Libertarian than a
patriarchist growing up like I used to
love watching Ben Shapiro Candice Owens
like I I loved watching The Daily wire
in high school
um and but sometimes occasionally I
would get a liberal idea right so you
know when BLM first came through when I
was in college
um I remember I would go home and like
repeat a talking point maybe from BLM
but the person that really made me
conservative was my father because any
time that I would come home with a
little liberal of an idea just a little
bit
um I would come home to my dad and tell
him
and he would just sit down and my dad's
like the calmest guy ever so he would
never get angry never get mad but he
would just like sit down and have a
conversation with me about why I was
wrong
um and I remember one thing that he um
he pointed out to me he said my first
name is Hannah for those of you that
don't know so he said Hannah uh two
dollars and one dollar out
and I said dad what do you mean he says
you put two dollars into something you
make one dollar out
and um you can only have so many of
those programs before you run out of
money
and this really stuck with me because
you know I've always been a more like a
compassionate person so I never wanted
to well I know you guys you guys might
not believe me today right but but I
actually
um but like even when I was a kid I
remember like I saved up all my money
for it was it was so funny
um I I saved up like 300 bucks back then
for for um I think I wanted a dog or
something I think I wanted a dog and it
was so funny because I went to school
and that was like when the tsunami
happened
um in I don't remember where it was I
was quite young but I gave like my my uh
my money to the teacher
um for for the tsunami it was kind of
funny my parents didn't even know so you
know I'll invest in like people that I
like or like I've always you know had
that
I I don't know where
compassion I get I know you guys might
not believe me but I swear but and you
know at some points like I could see
like some of the liberal ideas would
start to kind of make sense to me you
know you feel bad for people that grow
up in terrible situations you want to
help them out
um but my dad really would just break
down like why all of these programs are
not helping people and really like the
biggest form of compassion you can you
can give someone is to Mentor them or
coach them and there are so many people
my dad just like mentored or helped like
like my dad um
uh one of his employees like worked for
him for 20 years and my dad like this
was just like a couple weeks ago he he
helped her move like he literally helped
her and her family move like that just
the type of guy my dad is but he he
explained to me that like all these free
programs like they are not actually
compassion because they don't help
people move up economically and so you
know when Trump ran the first time I
wasn't overly political
um so I I didn't vote I had like a uh I
had some like I was always intro like I
watched the media but I just wasn't
crazy involved so I think I had a test
or something the first time he ran so I
didn't vote for anybody
um but when I saw the positive things
that he did in the country you know and
and this stuff wasn't even like I was I
was following super close but I just saw
people were making more money around me
uh people tended to have more money in
their bank accounts but my parents
business was doing better people I knew
that had businesses were doing better
and it there was just some sort of like
hope in the country where it wasn't just
a career politician and growing up I
didn't see that hope under the Obama
Administration I didn't see that hope
under the Clinton Administration like
Trump was different and you know that's
why in the next election that
I would argue was stolen but you know I
voted for him and there there's just
been like a hopelessness a bit the last
couple of years when
people the future just doesn't look
bright and under trump it was different
so you know that's why I support Trump
in this election like people have asked
me who I'm voting for I really do like
Trump I'm open I think that the policies
that Trump passed helped America people
had more money in their bank accounts I
think the policies that Trump passed
really just helped Middle America they
helped the average guy and I think we
need to push
candidates that are here to help the
average men and the average families in
America so that's the story of how I
became conservative and why I support
Trump so
you know and I also like that Trump just
really doesn't stand for any of this
craziness So speaking of craziness there
was a gynecologist who was accused of
transphobia for refusing to treat a man
can you imagine in France a gynecologist
is accused of transphobia for denying
care to a biological male the doctor
declared that he does not feel apt took
offer care to a biological man no matter
how much he feels like a woman the
partner of the trans who was denied care
left a negative comment in Google about
the rejection and expressing that they
were discharged coldly
Victor acharian professional of the
clinic responded to the complaint
explaining that he is a gynecologist and
that he cares for actual women and is
not equipped to care for men no matter
how much they shave or tell the
secretary that they have become women my
examination table is not designed to
examine a man he said but the
controversy around this story continues
to grow
that's amazing yeah I mean it's not
helpful to let these people live in
delusion these are people with mental
disorders they're they're not they're
not right in the head and it's okay if
I'm 300 pounds and everybody around me
is telling me that I'm healthy is that
kind is that nice why is it nice to
allow trans people to live in delusion
um men or men women are women this is
basic biology
basic and it's not kind to let people
live in delusion it's actually not
helpful to them at all
and this is why I actually think it's so
important to Value honesty above all
else in truth we need to be in a society
where we value what is true and I wanted
to bring up a clip where my producer
King just went crazy on these only fans
models these only fans models go through
life
and they've never been told the truth in
their life and I I'm I'm saying men can
be with you without being married yeah
so I'm just trying to do a thought
exercise where we think of things from
the men's point of view this is just a
clear example that shows that women
actually don't know what men want and
they don't care they want a tight [__]
always be conditional like
all right you should actually have a
connection be conditional until it's
your conditions that's what you want to
say but it's it it should be about
connection this is why a lot of
marriages don't work as much because of
the woman it's because the man doesn't
have a connection they care more about
or what's her reputation how many bodies
has she got it's ridiculous like that's
why sneakers never get married because
he's got that mindset sneaker will
probably
read the point you just keep proving the
point you don't know man you don't know
what men want even the men that you
they've said what they want but they're
gonna get married still are they I'm
telling you and you you I'm trying to
even communicate to you you're not even
interested in listening you don't care
the way you're sitting like you just
don't care that's [__] it's the fact I
know what you want and the reality is
the reality is this is the problem that
that the Western and I say it
specifically the Western world is played
with women one don't have values they
don't understand what man wants and want
no you don't study politics there's
nothing to dig at you it's just reality
I'm just observing facts so women don't
understand values they don't understand
realities of life because even when the
other lady at the back was trying to
explain to you about what um the reality
it is of prenup and what things that
could come up when you do only you kept
bringing it back to yourself because you
actually are very selfish and you think
about only yourself you don't even care
about the other woman and I wanted to
raise a point this is this is a clear
example when men do things that are
quote unquote illegal or quote-unquote
fire for society you will never see a
man come out in on a public platform to
promote it to other men but you will
always see women come on platforms to
promote silly things promiscuous
behaviors
a man that was selling drugs and was
probably making everything
the same thing I'm trying to make a
point because
if you were to see a man that was
probably selling drugs or was into fraud
or whatever
that makes his money like that even if
he promotes it as his lifestyle you will
never hear him say like oh yeah I would
advise my son to do that so I advise my
brother to them men don't do that
because
we understand that as a man you're
responsible for yourself and you're
responsible for your actions and your
actions have a direct repercussion on
you and the people that surround you so
you would always like to keep that to
yourself but I know this is a trend
among women that you actually don't care
maybe you don't care maybe you don't
know she did say earlier that she she
said that if she was a girl and she was
thinking about doing it to think about
it properly and for a long time she
never promoted okay that's like saying I
would think think long and hard before
you sell drugs
so I want to point out do these women
seem like they have a plan
um so the woman that said marriage is
about connection that's so wrong guys
marriage is about Duty it's not about
happiness it's it's literally about Duty
and building families that's what
marriage is about what we've been told
it's about our feelings and connection
and that's what will make it that's what
will make it work wrong wrong nope wrong
wrong wrong
um and now we have a sugar baby
talking about how she has morals
I mean
like you wouldn't see a drug dealer
coming out and lecturing people on
morals like and and this is the thing
it's so interesting to see how King is
telling her what men want
and do the women listen no
um do they do they accept what he's
saying no and you guys think I'm making
this stuff up the thing with the sugar
babies okay and I want to give you a
different point of view now sugar babies
sex workers whatever
you know there are women that are in
unique positions I'm going to give you
an example of a woman
um Oprah didn't have kids I think she's
in a long-term relationship I don't
really care that's fine I don't know she
seems fine I don't maybe she wanted kids
I don't know but
in her lifetime okay she's not gonna be
a burden to anyone else
uh she's not gonna be a bird like you
know we could argue about her Politics
the stuff she's involved but but my
whole point is if you're going to live a
life of being selfish and being alone
the issue is most women can't pay for it
so then who ends up having to pay for
the men the average man either through
taxes and government incentives or
giving them useless jobs to make them
feel like they're doing something
um I you know even I'll even give you I
we're not fans of Kim Kardashian here
all right we're not we don't like net
negative on society
but at least she can pay for her
decisions 85 percent of the women that
do this stuff have zero plan okay zero
plan so either they're gonna get married
which the stats don't really
show that their marriages will work out
right so they get married and they get
divorced and then what do they do they
get money from some sucker and that's
the problem is the entire system allows
women to make these bad decisions with
no consequence you know do what you're
gonna do you know I I think there's
better options and worse options
whatever but my issue is when you make
other people pay for your freaking bad
decisions why do the men have to pay for
only fans models to exist later because
they can't pay for anything on their own
why does some simp have to pick up the
pieces and then get screwed over in
divorce court because uh these chicks
can't get a real job
and the funny thing is our grandmothers
and great-grandmothers it's such a
misnomer that women used to not be able
to work okay women used to work have to
work twice as hard for a worse lifestyle
we have better standards of living than
any women in all of history yet were
more mentally one stupid and two uh
mentally deranged and less happy than
ever because women are happy serving a
good man in their life that's what we're
happy doing we you think you think we
used to live on farms and just be like
these housewives that didn't do anything
are you are you mad are you stupid
um this idea women women used to have to
work twice as hard for a worse lifestyle
but the problem is now we will not go
down in lifestyle for a family and you
want to do that fine pick your poison
whatever it's 2023 but
pay for it and you really think guys
like think about it do you think any of
these chicks are going to be able to pay
for it
really
and and you see it over and over again
you know there's examples of celebrities
that were world-renowned Superstar women
that are now living in apartments with
other people now because they weren't
smart with money women need men for
structure it's not a one it's a need
name one woman
that didn't have a man help her to get
successful Kim became a billionaire when
she was married to Kanye
I don't I don't think that was a I don't
think that was a coincidence
um Oprah was signed to a man's TV
network you know most women that are
successful in business have some sort of
male Mentor sorry guys don't shoot the
messenger but you know what
maybe I'm crazy maybe I just you know
don't know what I'm talking about maybe
these only fans models are just gonna
make amazing wives and mothers someday
I don't know let me know in the comments
guys get yourself a women to vote
t-shirt today none of this debauchery
and craziness would happen if women
didn't vote like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel I'll talk
to you next time